Hey,
it's okay, it's normal The sound of this refrigerator closing is normal, and the
principal's rhythm doesn't change as usual.
I'll leave it on the spot,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah ah, ah ah ah
Hiding it will only put Xiao Qiao at a disadvantage.
I didn't even listen to it I
was embarrassed until my neighbor told me today
Yeah, no, no, I was going to do it It's just a matter of timing, after it's clear,
who wrote it It
's good to stamp it
[music]
rar
8 It's not a rookie, it's a cooking utensil It
looks like it can be used to cook even the most masochistic girl I guess I
still don't remember it I didn't
have it
me
goodgood far good good good
ano ang